on Thursday President Trump spoke in
Poland where he laid forth his plans for
NATO Article five common defense he said
that the United States quote has
demonstrated not merely with words but
with actions that we stand firmly behind
article 5 our defense is not just a
commitment of money is it it is a
commitment of will Trump went on to
explain quote our own fight for the West
does not begin on the battlefield it
begins with our minds our wills and our
souls he even warned the Russian
government directly quote we urge Russia
to cease its destabilizing activities in
Ukraine and elsewhere Trump also stated
his support for missile defense in
Poland against Russia this should have
been a ringing rebuke to the American
media who have declared Trump a Putin
shill for nearly a year instead the
media decided to focus on the fact that
Trump received warm praise from the
Polish people CNN's actual headlines -
the real headline quote Trump showered
in Polish praise backs NATO's Article
five it's difficult to recall CNN
running a similar headline during
President Obama's magical mystery
European Tour's the media also went nuts
over Trump ripping CNN while overseas
NBC's Chuck Todd tweeted quote a
thrashing of the American press corps
and Intel community in Eastern Europe of
all places could Putin have asked for
anything more
well yes Putin could have asked him or
he could have asked for a president who
wanted to give him flexibility and
withdrew from a missile defense in
Eastern Europe and handed Syria over to
Vladimir Putin he could have asked for
that and actually gotten it it's not
pleasant that President Trump attacks
the media while he's overseas it's
unpresidential but I mean this is Donald
Trump says that any giant shocked but
the media's willingness to ignore the
real story in Poland that Trump
forcefully chided his supposed
conspirators in election hacking the
segment said with a missile defense
system to defend against them that he
went after their aggression in Ukraine
in Syria that's the real story they took
material steps to check those
territorial ambitions Ciena ignores all
of that the media ignore all of that
because they are more interested in
getting President Trump even over stupid
issues I'm Ben Shapiro this is the
venture hero show
okay so if you don't know anything about
wine we're going to just straight it and
thank our sponsors over at wink if you
don't know anything about wine if you
are invited over to meet us for dinner
and you don't know wine from a bottle of
Quetta maghreb juice very Jewish
reference then you need to go to winks
calm because wink calm not only allows
you to get an inexpensive terrific
bottle of wine it also tells you what
kind of wine your friends will like and
that you will like you actually go on
their it profiles your taste palate
tells you kind of what wine goes with
what food and they recommend a wine just
for you it's try wink calm t ry winc
calm you take that brief palate profile
quiz and they recommend a distinct and
interesting wine customized to your
palate shipped directly to you right now
wink is offering listeners a 20 bucks
off your first order when you go to try
blink comm slash been try wink comm
slash been again it's winc comm slash
been they'll even cover the cost of
shipping
try wyndcomm slash pin you get that
complimentary shipping you get that $20
off your first to order and these
bottles are like 10 bucks apiece so
pretty great deal try blink calm and
make sure that you never show up at
somebody's house with a crappy bottle of
wine again instead bring the wine that
will have them all talking that you will
enjoy as well so even if you don't like
their company you can at least get drunk
off to wine and really enjoy try winks
calm / Ben go over and check it out for
that you also use the splash pens that
they know that we sent you okay so
president Trump is over in Poland and
he's been speaking over in Poland about
missile defense and about Russian
aggression and about article 5 so for
months we've heard that President Trump
was going to draw from NATO now some of
this was Trump's own fault he kept
talking about how NATO was useless and
obsolete now
didn't pay their bills well now he
finally goes where it is necessary for
him to go to talk about NATO and that is
the countries that border the Russia
that would like to invade Eastern Europe
so he went over to Poland you recall
when President Obama was president he
helped dismantle a missile defense
system in Poland he took it out of
Poland they were defended against
Russian aggression Trump goes over there
and he says we are going to help you
reinstall that missile defense system
against Russia then he says we want
Russia to stop its territorial ambitions
in Ukraine and in Syria so in other
words this is not spoken like a guy who
spends his days
coordinating with Vladimir Putin on just
what Vladimir Putin wants but that is
not stopping the media from portraying
it that way to the media are fully
invested at this point there's
illusional okay we have a delusional
media and a delusional left they are
fully invested in the idea to twofold
idea number one Hillary didn't actually
lose and number two Trump is going to be
impeached at any moment these two ideas
are related but the idea is that Hillary
didn't actually lose because she could
never be beaten by a dunderhead like
Trump therefore it must have been that
Trump was colluding with Russia and
therefore we are going to search for
evidence of that collusion even where
none exists the Trump is out there
saying all of this anti-putin stuff it
has to talk about missile defense in a
way that Obama never did
he's never guaranteed flexibility to
Putin in return for anything and yet and
yet the media is treating this as though
Trump actually went there and made a
stop to Putin so Adam Schiff is on CNN
he's on CNN every two minutes Adam
Schiff because apparently he just lives
next to the camera for CNN at the
Capitol he actually sleeps on the floor
like he's sleeping out of the
Thanksgiving Day Sale and he and then
they wake him they wake him up in Adam
Schiff pops up put on a little makeup
and goes on TV Adam Schiff he says well
you know what Trump was really doing
here is he refused to acknowledge
Russian hacking of the election so it's
true during the press conference Trump
was asked about Russia and their
interference in the election now number
one Russia didn't actually hack the
election a CNN reporter named Chris
Chalisa was on all over Trump he said
Trump wouldn't acknowledge that Russia
half the election Russia didn't hack the
election if anything Russia worked with
WikiLeaks to interfere in the election
by getting a bunch of emails from DNC
and then weaponizing them for release
during the election cycle undermining
election credibility but there's no
evidence of collusion social leza is
wrong but Adam Schiff says because Trump
refuses to acknowledge so-called
election hacking he's giving Putin
everything he could possibly want and
you heard Chuck Todd say that when Trump
attacks the media this is giving Putin
everything that he could possibly want
well how about when Barack Obama
routinely attacked Fox News throughout
his entire presidency was he giving
Vladimir Putin everything that he wanted
it's just possible that Trump may have a
legit complaint and here's the thing for
CNN every time they attack Trump and
suggest that he's in collusion with
Russia and giving Putin what he wants
all they're doing is undermining their
own credibility and lending credence to
everything that Trump says about CNN
Trump so far has done nothing egregious
in Poland in fact
his initial speech which a lot of people
were concerned about was quite good
right he talked about with clips of yet
but he talked about the the fact that
Western civilization had unite against
the Islamic fascists threat he talked
about how Russia was providing a threat
to Eastern Europe he paid homage to the
heroes of Poland's past right all of
this is great stuff there's nothing
wrong with that at the press conference
he ripped on CNN but at this point
that's wrote okay if you if you're
pretending that you're really shocked by
Trump's behavior it's not something
Trump's behavior is grand or glorious
and attacking American press outlets
while he's on the road but let's be real
about this it is the new normal okay we
can pretend all we want that it's not
the new normal it is the new normal so
why don't we focus on the fact that what
he's actually there to do not rip the
media but talk with the Polish that's
actually going quite well but the media
can never acknowledge that because again
point number one is that they think that
he didn't actually win the election and
point number two is they keep hoping for
this kill shot they keep hoping that the
time will come when they get this one
moment this one grand moment where they
reveal everything there is to know about
Trump and Trump just collapses his
presidency ends and they're basing their
ratings off of this okay this is a
ratings game for MSNBC and CNN proof is
in the pudding okay MSNBC last week
there's the spat between Trump that's
idiotic spat between Trump and Mika
Brzezinski where he was tweeting out
about her bloody facelift and all this
stupid nonsense the day after he tweeted
that morning Joe's ratings one of 70%
you think that MSNBC and CNN are not
invested in the fight with Trump you
wonder why they cover every Trump
tweeted though at the end of the world
one it raises their ratings because
Trump is ratings and two they are hoping
that they're going to stumble upon the
thing that finally ends Trump's rating
that Trump will basically oust himself
they won't have to do anything
Trump will just finish Trump and more
importantly their viewers are hoping
that their viewers are hoping that they
will be watching CNN on the day and time
when the world ends when Trump's
administration finally collapses none of
that is going to happen and so the
Democrats have built their entire
platform now it's really amazing the
platform around just hoping that Trump
clocks himself in the face of the
frying-pan
they have nothing to present there is no
program there are no ideas there is no
actual agenda the only agenda is just
insulting Trump and hoping he implodes
and saying were not that guy we're not
that guy and then meanwhile on the other
side there
publicans are sitting around going well
at least we're not Democrats so both
sides who are becoming each other at an
incredibly rapid pace right Obamacare is
now being reinsuring by a Republican
Senate Donald Trump's White House chief
strategist Steve Bannon is now talking
about raising taxes on the rich so
Republicans who are becoming Democrats
and Democrats who are hoping to become
Republicans are both pointing at each
other and saying what least were not
that guy this is the new politics in the
United States you wonder why people who
like ideas you know I like ideas why I'm
frustrated with the political situation
I'm frustrated because neither of these
things matters okay I am NOT a Democrat
is not a slogan I am NOT a Republican is
not a slogan your idea should be your
slogan what you're going to do should be
your slogan but nobody talks about any
of that crap because we are so ensconced
in this WWE fight fest where Republicans
slap Democrats and Democrats clap
Republicans and then they all go out for
a beer afterward right all these media
members go out for a beer with each
other okay they like each other this
idea the people at Fox News get don't
get along with people on CNN it may be
true for like Sean Hannity who actually
is a true believer but it's not true for
the vast majority of people at Fox News
those people have friends at CNN people
at MSNBC have friends in the White House
Joe and Mika were friends with Trump
until literally five seconds ago and now
they're not it's all a game okay it's
all a big game and the only losers are
the American people who are sit here
sitting here wondering okay well you say
you're not a Republican and you say
you're not a Democrat but how are you
different you look exactly the same to
me yeah and it's not just me saying this
okay these are the actual slogans that
are now being unleashed so yesterday the
Democrats unleashed their new slogan
okay there's a natural bumper sticker
that they are putting out there okay
this is their new democratic slogan we
can we can show it okay the new
democratic slogan really this is a real
thing it's not a parody was Democrats
2018 I mean have you seen the other guys
that's legitimately what it says on
their slogan I mean have you seen the
other guys that's their slogan so it's
not here's what we're going to do here's
why Republicans are bad it's just
Republicans are a crap show and at least
we're not them at least were not them
they don't have any other agenda right
their only agenda is we hate Trump and
we hate Republicans and they're making
this clear every day hoping and praying
Republicans destroy themselves and they
can just point and laugh so the
Democrats continue to push for for
example a commission on President on
President
hums Fitness okay you're not going to
ask President Trump under the 25th
amendment I know there's this crazy idea
floating around there and Oh Ross dude
had from the New York Times had talked
about it that somebody's going to invoke
the 25th amendment and claim that Trump
is incapacitated he's mentally incapable
of being president the Trump who is now
the president is exactly the same guy
who ran is exactly the same guy he has
been for all 71 years of his life I mean
nothing has changed he's not he's not
senile he's not had a drop off in
capacity if you think his capacity is
not up to snuff it wasn't up to snuff a
year ago either and if you think that he
was perfectly fine a year ago he's
perfectly fine now in any case the
Democrats are pushing really a
commission on presidential fitness they
are trying to claim the Trump is
incapable of actually being president
so Katy tur of NBC even she was looking
at this and going you guys have to be
crazy this is what you're wasting your
time on well of course it does because
the body is contemplated by the
Constitution in the 25th amendment it
was adopted 50 years ago we're in the
50th anniversary of this provision in
the Constitution and it's you know as I
said it's been used multiple times and
so this simply follows through on our
constitutional responsibility I hear you
could also do so far only been signed on
and correct me if I'm wrong by Democrats
Democrats who are controlled Congress
they don't control the Senate they open
show the house they don't control the
White House so there's not any
Republican support do you think that
this is a good use of time right now
well you know things in Congress I do
take time to happen and it's been you
know 50 years of the 25th amendment has
been in place but the body itself would
be nonpartisan it would only be
activated upon bipartisan bicameral
action by Congress so there's nothing
for anybody to be afraid of except for a
presidential incapacity and that's what
the 25th amendment was all about it was
adopted after the assassination of
President Kennedy and of course we've
had multiple assassination and the
assassination attempts take place in our
history we've had lots of presidents
incapacitated by different kinds of
illnesses physical and mental and so on
and so we need to be prepared okay so a
complete waste of time but Democrats are
relying on this because again they're
hoping against hope that there will be
some duets machinae that something comes
down out of the head
saves them from their own incompetence
and you can see their incompetence on
display terry mcauliffe is the the
governor of virginia he's somebody who
wants to run for president in 2020 and
he has asked okay so names and
democratic leaders like who are the
leaders of your party and here is his
attempt to name Democratic leaders
return States who said no dice you're
not getting the data and you'll never
get it governor I never get to talk to
you so you're going to have to forgive
me that when I pressed you on this a you
are a savvy guy you are plugged in
you've been around democratic politics a
long time you no doubt are having
conversations behind the scenes no doubt
those conversations are being had
probably every day who is the leader of
the Democratic Party right now I think
there are many leaders of the Democratic
Party I will always do give me a name
Devon Aaron give me a name I'm not going
to give you out say the governor so
we're leaving their states creating jobs
building infrastructure building an
education system that works we have to
balance our budgets unlike Washington
they print money they still can't
balance a budget we create jobs we build
infrastructure we do education
governor's need to lead the way and
listen I compliment the folks on Capitol
Hill we're doing what they're doing but
you know we need some action out of
Washington to help us compete on a
global basis and today we're not seeing
anything out of Washington broken you
are a governor are you talking about
yourself yeah oh no I'm chair of the
National Governors Association I love
all of our governors that we have today
okay so McAuliffe is obviously trying to
say that he's the leader but nobody
believes Terry McAuliffe is the leader
because Terry McAuliffe doesn't even
believe Terry McAuliffe is the leader
the internal McAuliffe is is more
colorless than a glass of water I mean
the guy is just you just dull is
anything that has ever been put on this
earth there are no leaders of the
Democratic Party and so they are
basically they're basically running back
to that slogan at least we're not
Republicans now they can do well with
that slogan I'll explain why in a second
but first I want to say thank you to our
sponsors over at frame bridge con so
frame bridge comm is where you go when
you want to get all of your stuff custom
frame custom frames cost a fortune I
have a lot of great art in my house some
of it not so great but all of it is
custom framed it costs a lot of money
frames sometimes it cost more for the
frame than it does for the art that's
not the case when you go over to frame
bridge comm you upload your photo from
your computer or directly from your
Instagram feed or if you have the
physical item you can actually ship it
to them they will provide secure prepaid
packaging so you can mail it in for
three and then you can preview your
photo online and any frame styles can
choose your favorite you can get free
help from your designer they should
provide you a designer the expert team
at frame bridge will custom frame your
item in days not weeks or months and
they will deliver the finished piece
directly to you ready to hang right now
if you go to frame bridge comm and use
my promo code Shapiro's you get 15% off
your first or frame bridge comm promo
code Shapiro's they have a happiness
guarantee as well so if you aren't 100
percent satisfied with your order they
will make it right again it's frame
bridge comm and use that promo code
Shapiro's you have an additional 15% off
your first order frame bridge comm promo
code Shapiro's it is more inexpensive
than going to a local shop it is better
because you actually gets a preview all
of this stuff and they will make it
right if you don't like it so again
there's nothing to lose frame bridge
comm promo code Shapiro's get 15% off
also use the promo code shapiro says
they know that we sent you okay so I do
want to explain why why Democrats can
win based on this and the reason that
Democrats can win based on they were not
Republicans is if Republicans suck okay
that's how you win right so Republicans
were able to win based on that because
they would say at least we're not Obama
at least we're not Democrats and then
people said well that's true I guess you
have a point
I mean this was basically Donald Trump's
slogan at least I'm not Hillary he said
it during the campaign many times it you
have no choice but to both for me at
least I'm not Hillary Clinton people
went well ya up for it alright
everything's good choo choo get on the
train
that was sort of Trump's slogan so it's
not that it doesn't work but it requires
the other party to suck a lot
fortunately for the Democrats the
Republicans do they suck a lot so we're
going to talk about how much the
Republicans suck and why they have
nothing and why that matters more than
the Democrats having nothing in just a
second for that are going to have to go
over to daily wired.com so first of all
before I say this I just want to thank
the folks over at the blaze for
providing us this space today I want to
thank Glenn and Glenn back who had me on
the show earlier and Jonathan Schreiber
who's a CEO over here I want to thank
all the people with the blaze for
providing us the space because it really
is magnificent no we didn't actually
just we said we're going to have a new
studio but our new studios did not
involve us involved in an armed takeover
of the blaze they're just lending us the
space because they're kind and generous
people so thanks for that anyway if you
want to go over and subscribe so you can
see the rest of the show live from these
beautiful new studios that we just
hijacked and will refuse to leave then
you have to go over
komm $8 a month gets you a subscription
and that means you get the show you get
the the show live you get the mailbag
which we'll be doing tomorrow why'd you
get grooves show Andrew Clavin show
which you should totally listen to you
can get that live you can you can get
his his mailbag as well and then you can
also get the website experience ad free
which is pretty cool if you get the
annual subscription right now for a
limited time only you still get the the
free signed copy of the book that I
wrote with my father about baseball say
it's so really fun book you get that
free and signed when you get an annual
subscription also July 10th I mean the
clock is running down July 10th the the
rates go up so you want to make sure
that you lock in that lower rate right
now over at daily wire.com when you
become a subscriber so go over and check
it out we are the largest conservative
podcast in the nation
[Music]